hausgemachte Kroketten sind ganz schön
viel Arbeit immer mehr Restaurants
servieren deswegen fertig Kroketten und
gaukeln die hausgemachte Küche nur vor
rette die Krokette Sebastian baut die
industriekokette nach und lüftet den
fließbandrick
die Industrie stellt die Beilage aus
zahlreichen Zutaten in Pulver vor mir
ein Klassiker der deutschen Küche mit
Ursprung aus Frankreich ich lege einfach
los
Sebastian
ohne Butter ohne Ei und ohne frische
Kartoffeln stattdessen setzt er auf
kartoffelpulver
Methylcellulose dient als Geliermittel
Palmöl und Butteraroma liefern den
künstlichen Geschmack
Mono und die Glyceride von
speisefettsäuren verbinden die Zutaten
mit der Flüssigkeit es entsteht eine
Zehe Kartoffelmasse perfekt für
Kroketten
meine krokettenmaschine eigentlich
Wurstfüller funktioniert aber perfekt
Sebastian lege stellt perfekt genormte
Kroketten her damit sie außen schön
knusprig werden Welt der sie in
preiswert im Paniermehl ursprünglich war
die Krokette ein ganz feines Essen
schön mit so einer Butter noch drinne
mit so einer Nussbutter so eine leicht
gebräunten Butter drinne vielleicht ein
bisschen Petersilie ein bisschen kreativ
gedacht mein Appell nach draußen
rette die Krokette viele Restaurants
setzen auf industriekroketten der
Vorteil eine Portion kostet nur etwa 30
Cent
[Musik]
man spart sich wirklich Arbeit auch
dieses Produkt braucht kein gelernter
Koch mehr machen nichts mit kartoffel
kochen weil da braucht man eine perfekte
Rezeptur sonst laufen sie aus sonst
funktionieren sie nicht richtig und
schauen Sie hier
das hier
ist eine perfekt
eine perfekt panierte Krokette und jetzt
rein weiße
Kopf
[Musik]
kartoffelig mit Butteraroma
so kennen wir sie
in riesigen Fabrikhallen entstehen
fertige Kroketten am Fließband schnell
einheitlich billig und so landet diese
kartoffelbeilage als Fertigprodukt für
die Friteuse bei den
restaurantbetreibern
[Musik]
als ursprüngliche Kartoffeln selber zu
kochen
die industriekroketten gibt es im
Schnitt für 30 Cent Proportion billig
aber sehr weit entfernt von der
traditionellen Krokette in Zubereitung
und Inhaltsstoffen
kann dieses Produkt Restaurantgäste
täuschen
das will Sebastian herausfinden es er
wird seinen Gästen zwei verschiedene
industriekroketten können die als
handgemacht bestehen
also ich glaube das ist eine gekaufte TK
ja das ist eine selbstgemachte weil ich
finde die schmeckt und riecht nach
Muskat und ich glaube es wird bei der
Industrie nicht so stark verwendet also
welche schmeckt euch
Besserung kann ich verstehen welche
Variante schmeckt ihr euch besser
okay
[Musik]
also mir hat auch das andere also die
Variante besser geschmeckt
eben weil die auch so ein
Kartoffelgeschmack hatte also intensiver
geschmeckt hat das waren ein großer
Unterschied wirklich das war viel mehr
butziger und das waren so love die
Füllung hat total auf die Panade
Vergleich aber ich fand die Füllung
irgendwie love
bei einigen Gästen geht das
Industrieprodukt tatsächlich als
selbstgemacht durch wir haben uns
anscheinend bereits einen vorgefertigtes
Essen im Restaurant gewöhnt
[Musik]
Fertigprodukte wie die Krokette haben
die Gastronomie erobert viele Betriebe
wissen sich nicht mehr anders zu helfen
[Musik]
wir haben Fachkräftemangel in der
Gastronomie Corona ist natürlich noch
mal verschärft also das hat es noch mal
schlimmer gemacht ich würde sagen jeder
Betrieb den ich kenne ist am suchen
die Nachfrage nach guter deutscher Küche
ist groß geschätzt
55.000 Restaurants gibt es aktuell
gleichzeitig mangelt es an ausgebildetem
Personal seit Jahren sind die Zahl der
Auszubildenden
2020 waren es mit 16.400 fast halb so
viele wie noch 10 Jahre zuvor auch die
Zahl der Köche insgesamt ist auf dem
niedrigsten Stand der letzten zwei
Jahrzehnte Köche arbeiten
durchschnittlich 44 Stunden die Woche
oft abends und am Wochenende dabei
verdienen sie im Schnitt nur
2.100 €. es wäre ein Beruf den man
ergreifen sollte
aber es ist einfach gerade nicht so dass
er sehr attraktiv ist vor allem in
Deutschland hat die Wertigkeit von der
Gastronomie jetzt nicht gerade
zugenommen man hat zwar viele
Kochsendungen und so weiter und das ist
irgendwie in aller Munde aber die
Wertschätzung ist irgendwie nicht so da
[Musik]
viele Restaurants gaukeln die
hausgemachte Küche nur noch vor die
Industrie hat mittlerweile sogar
internationale Spezialitäten wie hat das
Bravas oder extra feines kartonsortiment
allein der kartoffelspezialist awiko
kommt auf 107 verschiedene fertige
Kartoffelprodukte für Gäste sind die
schwer zu erkennen
allerdings ist die Industrie ja auch
schlau und macht mittlerweile viele es
das handgemacht ausschaut also das
einfach nicht mehr so perfekt ist und
wenn dann der Geschmack jetzt nicht
komplett übersalzen oder sehr
glutamathaltig ist dann schmeckt man es
auch nicht immer
vorgefertigtes Essen ist ein
Milliardenmarkt selbst Spiegeleier
werden für Restaurants tiefgekühlt
geliefert pro Stück für 64 Cent und
damit dreimal teurer als ein frisches Ei
also ich denke schon dass das mein
frisches Ei war also ich glaube nicht
dass das jetzt zusammengesetzt ist aus
getrennt Eiweiß und Eigelb dafür sieht
es eigentlich schon recht natürlich aus
eben auch weil die sehr unregelmäßig
sind also es ist jetzt kein exaktes
dass man es mehr handgemacht macht die
fertigen Spiegeleier sind für Mikrowelle
oder Kombidämpfer optimiert auf diese
Weise können schnell große Mengen
produziert werden ohne das etwas
anbrennen kann
also Hersteller Empfehlung hatte ich
jetzt keine aber viel kann man glaube
ich nicht kaputt machen es ist schon
durchgegart ich denke mal wegen Hygiene
und Lebensmittelsicherheit gelingsicher
und vielfältig einsetzbar so bewirbt der
Hersteller die Tiefkühl winkeleier
gefroren sind sie 18 Monate haltbar
also für ein tk-spiegeleier bist mir
schlimmer vorgestellt
geschmacklich neutral und es ist einfach
trocken weil es natürlich über gart
ja ich würde es jetzt nicht wollen ich
kann irgendwie nachvollziehen wenn
jemand sowas braucht für große Massen
aber ich würde sagen jeder bekommt ein
frisches Ei natürliche bessere Qualität
hin der Vorteil so entstehen komplette
Gerichte nur in der Mikrowelle
Spiegelei Kartoffelgericht und Soße
möglich ganz ohne Herd Koch und Küche
extrem günstig für Restaurants und die
Lebensmittelindustrie